i i got to see fidel speak one time man
no you didn't at a conference yeah
really
in cuba at a conference wow and they put
a lot of meat out front they put a big
couple meat trays out front they happy
fly blindfolded
they had uh
no joke look up horse meat chin what is
it
what's horse meat i know you probably
have some in your lunch today but what
is it i would totally eat horses poor
sandwich google tallest dog
[Laughter]
ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb one
you can't argue there's something about
me you have no idea what you're saying
[Music]
hey sammy j here i got a debate club for
you which one of your wives do you think
is best for theo vaughn let's go down
the list we got eric's wife
she's always dressing up
she's probably running the show he might
not like that
chris's wife
might be the best fit
uh brendan's wife that woman would
probably put him in check 24 7. he'd be
like give me the [ __ ] out of here but
nonetheless all three of them are
probably great let's uh let's see what
you boys got to say
i already know the answer to this one
it's a great question i think i do it's
your way yeah i think it's chris yeah
because she's the most yeah she's yeah
she's she that's that's the role dog
right there
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean she
i'm very difficult to be with and yeah
so probably so
we don't even know which means
you know
he'll be taking a break from the
marriage you know what i mean
babe i gotta i'm gonna be gone for like
two months
he's going to pay all the bills and [ __ ]
out of his pocket
i'll still keep paying the bills
you do mike michael put you in that
guadalajara hard scarf man she runs a
tight ship yeah i think i'd probably
i'd probably go with like a
i don't know i'll probably go with a
foursome or whatever but yeah oh hey you
do all three yeah by the way what is
what is your type
like truly like both let's start
emotionally and physically
i feel like not i feel like maybe not
white yeah i would date i'd take
different types of ladies man
if you're well documented if you could
but what's your type though if you had
to pick oh you want me to answer hot
chris how about that well yeah okay i
understand but yeah but come on that's
that's the baseline yeah
i mean it just has to be a woman that i
really like you know but what do you
really like
like like for instance do you like
someone that because some people like
women that roll with the punches some
people like women that take the reigns i
mean you know exactly have you even
thought about this or or is it just
something i haven't thought that much
about it yeah
some guys don't you think you should
think about it yeah but some guys don't
i agree i think you're right i think i
probably need to
yeah i could probably invest more time
into thinking about what do i want you
know because i think that there's like a
like a um what do you call it like a
minimum standard everybody should have
whatever that is for you you know so if
it's like oh they do you want somebody
has a job they got to have their own
place they got whatever it is whatever
you know what that's funny but if that's
one of your things huge jokes
some people couldn't even draw their
wife from the neck up they have no idea
all right
but that's not the stuff we know what
race we're talking about for you i feel
like it has to be something else man
that's like you'll probably want someone
who's comfortable in their own skin has
their own [ __ ] going on so they're not
all about understanding but also holding
[ __ ] down yeah i understand you're like
an outdoorsy person do you like someone
who likes to travel or you want someone
that's okay with not doing [ __ ] cause
like for instance like on on my
honeymoon right i don't want i'm not
gonna go parasailing right right right
i'm not gonna go i don't wanna die come
on i don't want none of that stuff but
we did the london eye which is like a
really slow ferris wheel that takes a
half an hour and you can look over
oh they did okay this one's bigger than
that one and it looks it looks so you
could look over london and it's like
that's not adventurous that's no no no
no but i'm saying you were talking about
being high up
so that's where my mind
i'm just saying you know
eric's back on a cruise ship
thank you for watching
just but not going high just behind the
boat
just jellyfish [ __ ]
dude you just you just
just algae all over history
[Music]
back
[Music]
how's
[Music]
and the sting and the wing
you